this episode was powerful Lucchese's
fighting for as long as it as a man this
episode was sexual this episode was
incredibly freaking confusing
how does make you feel how's it made me
feel do you want to know how it makes me
feel this is your Bachelorette episode 5
recap I'm Lauren Zima grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rosy hi
everybody
Oh are we alright are we ok I'm not ok
what an episode I've brought two bottles
of wine today you have two bottles of
wine my rose gold wine opener Lupe
everyone loves me I don't want to give
you clarity that's all I want for you
the gorg broke that feels on-brand for
this episode nothing is working
oh my god all right
here we go let's just keep trying let's
be like Hana and let's just keep trying
do you want to know how it makes me feel
no matter how difficult it is no matter
how nonsensical it is let's just keep
digging in trying to make it work right
why not no matter how many red flags
they're coming our way let's follow our
heart the rose a is a more reliable
effort to pursue
I'm sorry I also have my self-care
wineglass everybody okay why do I need
all these things because this episode
was insane what did you guys think are
you over the luke pee stuff at this
point let me know in the comments below
let's get into it
let's save that for later it's just good
to know what's there it's comforting
we left last week with a to be continued
tonight we are back at the rose ceremony
with the Luke's and tonight things are
powerful so Luke Pete tells Lucas again
that he's not here for the right reasons
I just don't see a fit for him because
he's not the right fit for Hannah that's
not what not being here for the right
reasons means so you're speaking for her
now and this is going to be a theme
isn't it Luke piece saying confusing
things I'm just going based off what
she's expressed to us do not drink every
time Luke piece says something confusing
I can understand how you can feel like
they're being deceived okay I can
understand your frustration right now
and I've admitted to Hannah and I've
admitted to you both that I don't even
know you that well so Luke B is making
no sense because then he says that he
had no business in saying whether Lucas
was there for the right reasons but
that's exactly what he just did I don't
have any business saying whether you're
here for the right reasons or not you
know we're all gonna we're starting to
feel crazy and it's gonna keep on going
is it that way kneed me in the head
while I was down on the ground I was
trying to step over you man Lucas brings
up the whole meaning in the head thing
again and I just want to clarify quickly
because I saw in the comments and like
on Twitter and everything you guys were
saying no no we saw the incident we did
see the tackle but I think there was a
lot of talk about like how it ended the
kneeing in the head that kind of thing
and that was the part I felt was missing
and that we needed to see I also would
have liked a lot more angles just to
really understand and most importantly
what is concerning me about Luke be more
than anything is the overt lying I don't
remember how it happened to be all
completely honest with you he's
they didn't remember it heating please
go up there and tell her the truth yeah
well he told Luke he was gonna tell
Hannah that he was wrong he didn't these
are lies and lies hurt more than a meet
of a head don't they yes it depends on
the lie and the power of which the knee
was to the head but you know what I've
saved
[Music]
and things are powerful we are getting
powerful music we are getting powerful
shots of stained-glass windows
we are getting powerful words did you or
did you not I said to you you go talk to
Hanna
Luke P's voice is calm but his words are
power he isn't screaming but he is doing
damage and that is powerful
Luke B is one of those people where you
end up screaming at him because what
he's saying isn't making sense and he's
like why are you screaming it's like
because you're driving me crazy you're
making me feel crazy am I going crazy
okay
so Lucas pulls Hannah aside and that's
powerful and then mike says that Luke S
is quote fighting for his livelihood
fighting for his life as it as a man and
that is powerful and lucas tells hannah
to keep her eyes open her eyes open all
right
that's power powerful and then he leaves
what that was a powerful move loukas
self exits from the show I did not see
that coming did you guys think Lucas was
just gonna leave I was shocked and then
one rose is taken away still and math is
hard I don't know what that means but it
felt powerful and we say goodbye to John
Paul Jones and that's powerful and
Matteo and so I guess we're never gonna
get the real story about his sperm
donations that fathered a hundred and
fourteen children and that would have
been a powerful but we'll probably see
you guys in paradise by E cheers to John
Paul Jones and Matteo mmm hey guys it's
me it had been a while since we blogged
and I just wanted to blog because I
realized I should have said don't drink
every time I say powerful powerful
powerful powerful we are getting pellets
music powerful words are power powerful
as long as it as a man and that is
powerful
that's powerful and then he leaves that
was a powerful move math is hard I don't
know what that means but it's powerful
[Applause]
we are in Scotland it's not Rhode Island
is Scotland an island whatever I'm happy
to be there we're gonna get a sweeping
mores and we're gonna get to castles and
we're gonna get to cliffs and we're
gonna get I don't is this Sean Connery
I'm doing theirs mm-hmm
Indiana Jones in the last gross I don't
know what I'm doing but I love Indiana
Jones Last Crusade Junior don't call me
that please
but Stan Harrison Ford Sean Connery
together two of my childhood crushes
anyway
Hannah says let's reset I think we all
should just reset in this new country
but I don't think we can do you grace
think we can we are too deep in this
loop these stuff we can't just eradicate
it so maybe we can't reset but we can't
move forward Mike Mike is the one-on-one
and Lupe's face
[Music]
but mike is smiling and then loopy is
defending himself again my time the
other guys you weren't there you don't
know what you speak up
this is his constant defense no one was
there guess what babe in not all but
some cases the cameras were so this is
gonna come out okay Mike Indiana's one
on one guys it's cute they're having fun
Hanna's cracking me up I loved how she
had a couple glasses of whiskey and she
was like a guy who loved Swagger I'm a
step a little bit more swagger
[Applause]
they'd haggis gross great I don't know
I'm up for trying new foods is this Loch
Ness monster I just love this date I
thought that they were wonderful what
did you think of Mike and Hannah's
one-on-one do you think Mike will be in
the Final Four
yeah they still as much as I like their
date I'm still wishing we had the
sailing date so I'm dressed like a
frickin Popeye impersonator today what
am I wearing
okay oh but then the show is the gift
that keeps on giving I miss Tyler see
and they gave me Tyler see in a tight
tear eating a date card okay you don't
have to be shirtless to look great
I'll have a t-shirt moment Tyler T okay
this is the first time this entire
journey I've been this nervous
so also loves the moment where Mike was
just really honest with Hannah about
being kind of nervous and revealed that
he had not been in love for five years I
had
for almost half a decade that seems like
a long time to me I hope that I really
find clarity and how I feel about her
Luke literally went from the first group
day where he was saying he's falling in
love now he's saying he's just excited
to see where this relationship is what
happened
the guys are back at the castle and
talking about how Luke peace feelings
are all over the place like one minute
he's saying he's falling in love with
Hanna the next minute he's saying maybe
he's gonna leave and I'm starting to
have one of these moments that I've been
having occasionally where I feel a
little bit bad for Luke P and I think
you know maybe he's just this guy who
like needs to go up a little bit maybe
he's just confused maybe he's
emotionally stunted for some reason and
then I kind of remembered but then again
he's doing things like saying but the
other guys aren't the right fit for
Hanna which means that he's saying that
he thinks he knows what's best for Hanna
and that's really controlling and also
then I remember that he lied like
several times that it was caught on
camera and then Devin puts it all into
perspective perfectly but honestly at
this point I just feel like he's a
big-ass douche community
okay the group date and we are at
another castle I love it dream fairy
castle the gamma not schooled castles
castles and my Scottish Irish Maj says
okay great thank you for confirming so
Peters looking oh now am i right it's
difficult I'm grouping the whole United
Kingdom together sorry Peter is just
looking so cute and smiley and when is
he not and then I have to say I was a
little disappointed because we're going
to do the Highland Games open to the
Highlands
we've done this before maybe on multiple
seasons of The Bachelorette I definitely
know they did it on Emily Maynard season
he's broke it broke the wood I'm not
gonna lie it was impressive Sean looked
friggin odd in Croatia for whatever
reason and like we've seen axe throwing
we've seen wood chopping just so many
times bow down to your queen bow and
then they're tackling each other again
and I mean honestly it's more sports I'm
over it I'm ready for something like the
labor pains date again where it's not so
much about the physicality but about a
funny scenario like maybe they all could
have gone whiskey tasting together and
see what happens where
and then we cut back to the other castle
and we realized that with Mike having a
one-on-one and everyone else being on
the group date that means Mike and Luke
are alone in the castle together that's
powerful and what comes out of it I will
say is bizarre I thought maybe we'd get
another argument but instead we get more
defining the monster is also apt to
inspire disbelief or faith that borders
on mania like remember Luke P was
holding up that phone in defining
Psychopaths now mike is defining the
Loch Ness monster something unexplained
exists underneath the surface and I'm
like where is he going with this Luke P
was on a phone Mike is reading a book
and we realized it's all building up to
a pun of the loop Ness monster I just
want to see it she's gonna realize the
real loopy
he's a loop Ness monster
tepid applause golf club
we're in Scotland I think golf was
invented there I don't know for sure I
feel like I've heard someone I didn't
hang out with a lot mention that
whatever back to the group date at
Castle 12c and this Scottish guy even
says this is the first post Bachelorette
Highland Games the first ever
Bachelorette Highland Games gentlemen
and welcome to the Highland Games you
know I don't even understand some of
these challenges like what's the milk
was the object to go fast when carrying
the milk or to not spill the milk
unclear to me and I'm not really sure
that anyone wanted any of it
but pilot Pete does love to soar like a
literal plane I love it if he's like I'm
just flying the planes
I gotta protect my cool wrestling and
then more sports they're wrestling in
kilts and why didn't they wear underwear
not wearing any underwear
so definitely concerned about showing my
butt I'm unclear I didn't I don't know
if anyone told them you can't wear
underwear it seems silly and there were
children present at that event and
things got revealed I saw all the
bagpipes the old haggis drink every time
Hannah wears a cute winter hat I like
her hats mm-hmm we haven't talked about
this much but what do you guys think of
Hannah's fashion and style this season
Jake Jed wins I don't know why or based
on what but okay and then the
after-party is at another castle
but it's wine not whiskey for me it
would be ignorant of me to ignore the
fact that today went so great leap he
wasn't on this great day
and luckily Hanna has realized and
acknowledged that Luke Pete like
shouldn't be the focus of everything
anymore it was a great day with these
guys without Luke beef bring us great
great so then she gets her time with the
guys and Jed and Hanna
forget the chemistry with Luke B let's
talk about the chemistry with Hanna and
je d mom's fan they are making out and
what I love is that this night is gonna
be Hanna making out with the guys in the
worst dress possible for the scenario
she's like yeah let's dress like like a
trash bag of things we have XE like
speaking of her fashion it's like I
think I can't I want what I can't all
right I want it like that would be but
it's not great it wasn't a good dress
for it but they pushed through and Jed
and Hannah are making out jazz Hannah is
on her but Jed's Hannah is on her but in
that trash bag dress and then Kevin
comes in world Kevin I kind of forgot he
was their houses shoulder who knows I
just think they're watching this for
like 15 20 seconds I'm like oh my I mean
mean Hannah have not kissed yet
and Kevin sadly it reveals that he and
Hannah haven't even kissed yet
how'd we miss that and he just like
watches them kids like 15 20 seconds I
just feel like Kevin is Kevin from home
alone like he's just like
and you can't stop watching course I
wish that was me then oh my god I'm
gonna need some more wine drink for
every time Hannah's gonna make out with
somebody and then I get it girl yes I
needed this to take me away from that
loopy stuff so Peter and Deanna are
making out there's is also awkward with
that dress and the pool table and when
is Peter not smiling is he smiling while
he's making out somebody tell me and
then Tyler and Hannah are making out
water the whip owned every place to make
out in the castle Hannah the true island
game Mike and Luke pee are still alone
in the other castle together it is like
a horror movie and then Luke P gets a
one-on-one date card and it was so
powerful the way he interpreted the card
wasn't it the date card said let's
figure things out one way or another I
think myself and let me know what you
guys thought interpreted that as let's
figure things out we might break up or
still be together
Luke took it as let's figure things out
one way or another we're gonna be
together no matter what one way or
another Luke we're gonna get through
this which way did you read it let me
know in the comments below
finishing up the group date Connor tells
Hannah I'm like totally gonna fight for
you I'm gonna fight for you
and his accent is so in stark contrast
to the Scottish accents and yes as all
the guys were amazing Oh amazing it's
also powerful and Jed gets the round
now it's time for Luke peace one-on-one
[Music]
here we go okay so I'm honestly not
gonna spend a ton of time on this
because it was too much time watching it
in the episode it wasn't it I felt like
I was in someone's like difficult we're
not getting anywhere
relationship fight from like their
college years and when it's all
unhealthy and no one knows what they're
doing and it's like it was painful for
me either today is the first one-on-one
with my future husband or it's the first
and last one-on-one date with Lee Hanna
starts things off seeming to say what we
interpreted the date card to mean that
this could be their first or last date
together a make or break and Hanna
confronts Luke with all the things she's
show the guys don't like you like I just
don't understand and Luke is just not
giving answers and this goes back to my
point that I brought up a couple weeks
ago I don't think that they really have
good conversations together I think that
their connection is very strong rare
physical chemistry but what have they
really talked about and this date
confirms nothing that's really not
adding up
Hanna can't even get Luke to have a
conversation with her anywhere I've ever
been in my whole life
everyone loves me she is having to
explain how to communicate I know but
don't say things like people love me
that she's so mad she is having to
explain what feelings are I don't know
what you want me to say do not drink
every time he Anna says please tell me
how you feel like how does make you feel
how does it made me feel do you want to
know how it makes me feel there's
feelings for have the things that they
say about what it means when I say how
do you feel
one more vlog we should have said drink
every time Luke says clarity I just
wanted to be clarity I want to give you
clarity it's just so many red flags and
I don't think that any relationship
regardless of the setting whether you
meet on a reality show or a dating app
or a garage sale or a sailing boat
should be this difficult this early on
right it's too much
can somebody talk to him about what it
means when I say how do you feel it gets
to the point where Hannah goes and talks
to the producers and she is saying can
someone go talk to Luke and explain
feelings to him she's essentially asking
the producers can someone go give Luke
therapy you have to talk about that and
it's like no we can't do that here today
we're on a kin cliff in Scotland Hannah
there's no therapists around it's just
you and Luke you're gonna have to keep
wishing through this that I need more
it's not even red flags anymore it's
like a red tablecloth a red blanket a
red quilt a red sail can we sail away
from this across the Narrow Sea Game of
Thrones reference to never film in
Scotland I don't know okay
ultimately she says that she cannot keep
making excuses for him when she's not
doing that for anyone else I can't keep
making excuses for him when I'm not
doing that with anybody else
good good realisation Hannah they go to
dinner
I'm so confused at this point I'm so
exhausted I'm over it I'm just like
Hannah walk away walk away Hannah and
she doesn't give him a rose but doesn't
say he's not gonna stick around
I think we're left on it to be continued
I honestly don't even know ah but I
can't quit weather on my fresh with her
Scottish RAM and the cliffs so whether
I'm sailing on a boat
I've gotta get up because I can take our
lives but they can never take oh I play
the Weinland games without a competition
okay next week on The Bachelorette we
end with a powerful trailer there are
tears
there are apologies there are Chris
Harrison sit-downs I need to know if
you're still in this
and you're capable of being in this
there are prayers oh my god what is
happening we have turned to Jesus Jesus
help us please please help us Jesus help
us and that was this episode what did
you guys think does Luke fee deserve yet
another chance
obviously we see him in the trailer so
he's not gone and so I guess evening
everyone
but did he deserve it who do you think
Hanna's heart lies with right now Hanna
said that part of the problem was her
heart was with Luke but her head wasn't
and I just want to tell her
Hanna you don't have to choose between
those two you should get both your heart
and your head with the same person and
hopefully that's what she finds in the
end or she just on her own
we don't know I've interviewed her she
hasn't told anybody if she's engaged or
not what do you guys think did Hanna and
her season with a proposal let me know
in the comments below I love you guys so
much thank you for powering through this
powerful experience that was also
painfully my numbing goodbye GCSE Rinna
a blue blaze rod that would be all right
are you not a salmon colored one no
speaking of colors er what do you think
of the how do I stay in it Scott
Scottish what's your go to do it I was a
scores brogue oh gosh
scores Scottish brogue what is your I go
I are in school what is your take on all
the red flags you know one must I'm
gonna I'm gonna adders to the squash
Prague offense course Prague is not like
a red flag a red flag is more like an
Irish accent what's broke a red flag is
like me when I've drank too much Rosie
I'm sorry you got Irish there